[Music]
award shows have their own caddy
correspondent to comment on red carpet
fashion
well the audience's are no exception
please welcome our own audience these
fashion assassin James Sinclair st.
Wallens oh my eyeballs are burning
let's see my first victim oh this is too
easy
what happened did you get dressed during
a blackout seriously you need to invest
in some Versace because that look is
vers sloppy next please and hurry Oh for
once for once I'm speechless
when did Old Navy overturn its
don't-ask-don't-tell power he must be a
real Patriot because that outfit sure is
dedicated to life liberty and the
pursuit of crappiness I'd go on but I
just had my eyeball put on suicide watch
who's next oh boy
lordy Lordy berry gordy what is that oh
look it's Andy Richter's more
fashionable cousin trendy Richter
you look you look like someone put a
hipster in a nerd in a blender and set
the blender on crap hey come on Queen
Daniel let's go make some Girl Scouts
cry
[Applause]